i love you movies
me too if you're a db fan who feels this
couple didn't get enough screen time
you're in luck
we're going to take a look at past
descendants 3 and see what could come
next for this cute couple
doug and evie have shared true love's
kiss but not what
let's find out how could you go camping
without me
what in most classic disney movies we
catch a couple fall in love
even though their courtship tends to be
a little fast by modern standards
come on ariel did you really have to
give up your voice for a dude you'd
never even talk to
after two characters share a meaningful
kiss they presumably live happily ever
after
until they get a straight to video
sequel that's nowhere near as good
as the first film like many great disney
romances evie and doug
experience true love's first kiss and
then their story as we know it
so far came to an abrupt end during
descendant 3.
if you're a dv fan then you know we
didn't get anywhere near enough content
of this sweet couple over the course of
the franchise
while malin then got to enjoy their
royal engagement evie and doug's fates
were left much more ambiguous
you're pretty great in there so are you
while they may not be in a rush to get
married we can definitely see it
happening for them
at some point and you can imagine what
an epic wedding evie would plan
yes she learned over the course of the
movies that she doesn't have to be the
fairest of them all but that doesn't
mean she doesn't love to look gorgeous
evie loves to sew and design her own
clothes look at the shoes
look at them and even has her own
clothing brand
maybe evie's four hearts will be rolling
out a bridal line at some point in the
near future
and since she's been applying blush
before she learned how to talk
she could save some serious cash by not
having to hire a makeup artist to do her
day of face
don't worry we know wedding days aren't
just about the bride
while doug may not be overly interested
in floral arrangements or even his own
wedding day attire there is one thing
he'll probably have input on
the music we have a feeling the
descendants cast would dance the night
away
to the dragon slayers if doug is put in
charge of the entertainment for the
evening
evie's mother may be the evil queen but
she's still a queen so we expect this
affair to have all the glitz and glamour
of a real-life
royal wedding would evie choose a subtle
sophisticated style like real-life royal
meghan markle
with a stunning glittery tiara of course
honestly the only impediment we see
to evie and doug getting married is
trying to figure out the guest list
no wonder people work of course they
both have plenty of friends but it's
their families that may end up giving
them trouble
even if you're not exactly a disney buff
you probably know that the evil queen
and the seven dwarfs don't exactly have
the best history together
what with evie's mom giving their
friends snow white a poisoned apple and
all
she and mal's mother maleficent are
besties like my waistline like the magic
wand hello but would the evil queen be
able to celebrate her daughter being
the fairest of them all on her wedding
day according to evie her mom isn't
exactly a barrel of laughs and we could
definitely see some awkwardness between
the bride and groom side of the wedding
they'll just have to make sure everyone
is seated far far away from each other
during this reception
we're eager to see evie's take on bridal
style but even her friends may have
trouble keeping up
in the real world pretty little liars
star troy and belisario
admitted to having anxiety over the
outfit she wore to the wedding of meghan
markle and prince harry
apparently wearing a fascinator isn't as
easy as it looks even though it does
lend a glamorous aesthetic to an event
the descendants have overcome
so much over the course of the series
will the next big challenge mal and jane
face be pulling off a suitable outfit
for evie and doug's wedding
at the end of descendants 3 mal removed
the barrier between auradon and the isle
of the lost and put up a bridge instead
and it's time that we take the barrier
down forever
so these two communities which have had
a contentious relationship for so long
will be merged together
and this is definitely going to shake
things up there will undoubtedly be a
lot of people who struggle to adjust
with the changes which is something evie
went through
in the first movie hi ho evie
evil queen's daughter she started out
being a little bit vain and shallow but
overcame that incredibly quickly
she's always been able to win people
over with her charming personality
so it's possible that she could help
other characters adapt to the changes
they're experiencing
we have a feeling evie and doug will
stick to auradon at least for now
and could help some citizens of the isle
of the lost acclimate to their new lives
doug once said that if evie's business
keeps growing i think in the next few
years you could buy that castle you
always wanted so we have a feeling these
two will have an amazing home together
we all know that evie is an incredibly
talented designer with a serious
creative streak
and she's received a lot of help from
her friends over the course of the
series
so it might be time for her to give back
and teach others how to create their own
clothes and develop their own sense of
personal style
evie's learned she's a lot smarter than
she once thought so we'd love to see her
become a teacher and help other kids
learn the same lesson she experienced
when she moved to auradon
hand me the glue gun
one of the many reasons we love doug and
evie together is because they make a
great team
even for someone as talented as evie
running a business
isn't easy and we've seen doug help her
out and grow her business
in descendants 2 he did some logistics
work for evie's clothing line
and we can definitely see him continuing
to support her since the two of them
make such a great team
he knows evie is more than just a pretty
face and she knows how smart
loyal and dedicated doug is which makes
them great romantic partners and great
business partners too
doug will likely continue to pursue his
passion for music
and enjoy many happy movie nights with
his wife and we know how much
evie loves movies with their jobs and
castle to care for we expect doug and
evie to be super busy but that doesn't
mean they won't find time to help raise
the next generation of descendants
of course we've all been eagerly
awaiting news about a descendants 4
and wondering what that could look like
the actors behind our favorite
descendants characters love their roles
but are understandably apprehensive
about making yet another movie
according to sophia carson she isn't
sure how a fourth film would work
without cameron boyce the descendants
franchise
changed all of our lives i don't think
any of us could imagine it without
cameron it's a difficult subject this
star portrayed carlos before suddenly
passing away due to a medical condition
his loss was devastating for his fellow
cast members and both sophia and dove
cameron
have expressed that they aren't sure
about continuing the series without him
but there could be a way we get more
descendants without cameron's absence
being quite so painfully obvious
sofia said she isn't sure if there's
much story left to tell for the original
descendants but sarah jeffrey has some
thoughts on the matter
she told entertainment tonight that
there are so many awesome possibilities
in this fictional world
that she'd love to see a spin-off
featuring some new characters
also a spin-off could happen with new um
new characters and new
daughters and sons of could we get to
see the next generation of descendants
it's possible that the next century in
the franchise will take place
after a considerable time skip when the
current cast has children old enough to
attend auradon prep
it would be interesting to see if this
school still holds the same level of
prestige as it did
in the original movies or if a new
school is developed
considering the new bridge between
auradon and the isle of the lost
would the kids of evie and doug choose
to go to auradon prep like their parents
or would they prefer to attend a school
on the isle
in the first movie evie was determined
to find herself a prince to marry
you have to take me with you yes
[Music]
but she soon realized that was really
her mother's goal and not her own
while she and doug might be able to
afford their own castle soon
is that still something evie wants or is
it another goal
imposed upon her by the evil queen
instead of splashing out on a giant
house for themselves
evie and doug could create their own
school which could take in students from
auradon and the isle of the lost
aurodon prep isn't for everyone and
there could be some more
creatively inclined students who would
appreciate hands-on training
in art music and design fields that doug
and evie know a lot about
doug comes from a big family so much so
that he struggles to remember all of his
uncle's names
evie on the other hand is an only child
so the couple might try to compromise
and stick to two kids
if we're going to be seeing aged up
versions of the descendants descendants
then we could see someone like one day
at a time star isabella gomez or sierra
ramirez
from the fosters playing their daughter
if they have a son maybe
on my block actor diego tanoko would be
a good fit
if evie and doug have kids we're sure
they'll love hearing about the adorable
love story their parents experienced
usually these kinds of stories tend to
end with true love's kiss
true love's kiss works every time
but this was just the beginning of their
lives together when evie first traveled
to auradon she was party to the
villain's evil scheme to release those
on the isle of the lost by getting the
fairy godmother's magic wand
and she had her own mission to find a
prince but before long she realized that
chad charming was
well less than charming she ended up
falling for doug who stuck up for her
and saw right away how smart
talented and caring she could be evie
said doug helped her realize that she's
more than just
a pretty face although she certainly has
one of those too
for the first time it's like i'm more
than just a pretty face
even though doug isn't a prince he has
plenty of good qualities that caused
eevee to fall head over heels
but since she struggles with shyness
from time to time it was hard for her to
confess her feelings
but when push came to shove or rather
audrey's spell
impacts the kingdom evie was forced to
puck her up and make her feelings for
doug clear once
and for all it's easy to get caught up
in the love story between mal and ben
but we think evie and doug have a great
tale too we have no doubt they'll
overcome any and all challenges by
sticking together
what do you think the future holds for
evie and doug is true love enough to
keep them together forever
or will their feuding families tear them
apart share your predictions with us
and your fellow descendants fans in the
comment section below
make sure to click on that subscribe
button and turn on your notifications to
catch our newest videos
we'll see you next time
you